I haven't done that much product  placement in my movies because for the  most part I've actually been usually  refused  if I want to use uh I think my very all  my first scripts always had some scene  that took place at a Denny's  because I had many scenes in my early  20s that took place at a Denny's and uh  and I was Reservoir Dogs in the original  script at the opening scene where  they're all talking at a Denny I don't  typical society says I have to the  opening scene in um Pulp Fiction pumpkin  and honeybunny at a Denny's I love you  honey bunny in both cases Denny's goes  no truthfully I don't ever notice it  unless it's super obvious yeah and then  when it's super obvious it becomes  ridiculously obvious